[Music]
We've all experienced sadness, but usually,
our sadness does fade over time and gets better.
But what happens when the sadness lingers?
Depression goes beyond normal sadness, it
can become an all-encompassing disorder.
There are different types of depression but
the most common is known as Major Depressive
Disorder.
According to the DSM-V, Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual of Mental Disorders, to have major
depressive disorder, you must meet five of
the possible criteria outlined in the DSM-V
and at least one of the symptoms must be depressive
episodes.
But what other signs are there of depression?
How do you spot if your friend or even you
are suffering from this disorder?
Watch on to find out 7 important signs of
depression.
One; neglecting friends and hobbies.
Another frustrating symptom of depression
is something known as "Anhedonia". This means
the loss of pleasure from activities which
would usually be fun.
This leads to neglecting activities in people
as they no longer give the person with depression
any sense of pleasure or fun.
According to "Psychology Today" writer Faith Brynie, it is one of the most common symptoms
of depression.
So if your friend no longer seems interested
in their hobbies like Pokemon Go, playing
guitar or dancing it may be a good time to
check in with them.
Two; changes in sleep pattern.
Our sleep pattern is incredibly important
for our mental health, often changes to our
sleep pattern are one of the signs that were
suffering mentally.
This is particularly an issue as an irregular
sleep pattern can make depression worse.
Depression can cause insomnia, too little
sleep or hypersomnia, sleeping too much.
These changes in sleep pattern also tend to
result in a decrease in overall energy. This
symptom is very common.
Nutt Wilson and Patterson found that 75% of
depressed patients reported insomnia and 40%
reported hypersomnia.
So if you notice a change to your sleep pattern,
it might be a sign you're depressed.
Three; change in appetite.
Another thing that depression can influence
is our appetites. Some people with depression
find their appetite is much lower, feeling
unable to eat.
Conversely, some people with depression have
an increased appetite and may turn to food
to comfort eat.
Simmons et al found that certain brain areas
were involved in whether someone with depression
lost or increased their appetite.
So, if you notice your friends' appetite seems
to have changed drastically, that might be
a sign they're suffering from depression.
Four; low self-esteem.
Self-esteem is something that is often majorly
affected by depression. Depression can make
you only see the negative things about yourself
and downplay your achievements.
This is a serious symptom of depression as
it can lead to people feeling worthless.
It's even been shown in studies that low self-esteem
as an adolescence is a risk factor for depression
as an adult.
If you feel like there's nothing positive
about you or you have friends who always seem
to put themselves down, it could be due to
depression.
Five; decrease in hygiene.
One way the lack of energy from depression
can manifest is a decrease in someone's hygiene.
Often those with depression struggle to shower,
clean their teeth or other self grooming habits
we take for granted.
This is due to their fatigue and lack of motivation
to complete tasks.
So, if your friend is looking less clean and
groomed it might be due to a depressive episode.
Six; irritability.
Do you ever find that everyone and everything
is getting on your nerves?
Do you feel like you're tense and pent-up?
Irritability is one of the symptoms of depression.
When you feel so negative about everything,
it can make even little things feel incredibly
annoying.
Besharat et al also suggests depression causes
dysfunction in mood regulation, meaning anger
is more likely to be displayed.
So if you notice you or a friend have a shorter
fuse than usual, it might be worth looking
into why that is.
Seven; Flat emotions.
There is a misconception that depression is
all about feeling sad all the time. This however
isn't the case.
One other symptom of depression is known as
"Flat Mood". This is where a person's mood is
dull.
Often people say they feel numb or like they
can't feel anything at all. They don't feel
sad but they also can't feel happy either.
If this feeling is something you've experienced,
you might want to seek help as you may be
suffering from depression.
If you feel like you strongly relate to the
signs in this video, you should seek professional
help.
A doctor will talk to you about your symptoms
and may have you complete a self-report questionnaire
to help diagnose you.
Once your doctor suspects you have depression,
they will discuss treatment options such as
medication and therapy with you.
We hope you found this video helpful.
If you did, be sure to like and share.
Follow our channel for more psychological
content.
Hello everyone, my name is Dan [?] and
today we are at Steve Nash at Burnaby on Kingsway
and today we are going to be doing the RYU
One More Rep challenge for mental health.
And I challenge everyone of you to come and
join me and let's get started.
[Music].
There you go everyone.
Thank you for watching and if you do plan
on participating, make sure to tag Steve Nash RYU
as well as Psych2Go and if you have any inquiries
or have any questions, feel free to drop by
any Steve Nash location and we'll be more
than willing to help you out.